[Música]
la principal característica de la
hipocondría es la preocupación el miedo
y la creencia a padecer una enfermedad
grave
a partir de la interpretación personal
de alguna sensación corporal u otro
signo que aparezca en el cuerpo
se es más sensible a las sensaciones y a
los síntomas corporales
pero ese concepto es vago cuando se
compara a lo que se vive de verdad
siendo hipocondríaco
imaginen una noche un joven de 13 años
13 años que lleva 45 minutos encerrado
en un baño con pánico
pensando que iba a morir de cáncer en
algún momento porque tuvo un síntoma en
su cuerpo
ese joven no está solo
está con quién será su compañera por más
de 23 años
y contando
el joven era yo y mí
y la compañera era la hipocondría
3 cardiólogos 3 urólogos decenas de
exámenes sanguíneos neurólogos médicos
primarios les confieso
esto es agotador física mental y
económicamente
el centro no cede y de los ángeles se
estima que entre el 4 y el 6 por ciento
de la población padece de hipocondría
clínicamente significativa
la hipocondría se eleva a casi una de
cada 10 personas según la doctora que
ven acá ser y propietaria de el centro
de tratamiento para la ansiedad de
chicago
si las estadísticas señalan una
importante cantidad de personas en esta
situación porque la medicina no ha sido
proactiva para atacar este problema
ningún médico noto que yo tenía esto
bueno salvo dos y que de manera jocosa
me llamaron hipocondríaco
pero tampoco me definieron lo que era el
hipocondrio tuve que ir yo luego e
investigarlo
tres comentarios en internet en un vídeo
de internet llamaron poderosamente mi
atención acá una doctora una psicóloga
hablaba sobre la hipocondría
1era de andrea ella escribió que era
desesperante llevaba 15 años de
hipocondríaca y que su vida transcurría
entre ataques de ansiedad
jose de 15 años comentó que tenía un
temor gigantesco a las diabetes pero el
temor mayor era hacerse el examen por
miedo al resultado
el examen de sangre
y por último cristian de tan sólo 13
años dijo sentirse muy feo tenía
síntomas pero que el doctor siempre le
decía que no tenía nada pero su ansiedad
le provocaba mucho más síntomas raros
uso de esa palabra raros
y como esto como estos tres comentarios
hay miles interminables y cada uno es
una historia distinta
la falta de entendimiento y la
subestimación de la hipocondría solo
arroja gasolina al fuego
desde el fondo de mi corazón yo siento
que la medicina no le ha dado una
importancia necesaria
por supuesto al sentirnos incomprendidos
recurrimos al internet de forma
compulsiva a esto se le llama
cibercondría
hasta un término ya existe pero me
refiero a unas 100 veces al día ir a
internet en busca de explicaciones
y al final terminamos con más angustia y
más pánico
pero lo que debemos saber es que la
mayoría de las páginas que arroja el
internet como resultado de estos
artículos que aparecen son publicidad
pagada con la intención de que vayas al
médico y sin duda que han tenido
muchísimo éxito todos estos anuncios
para los hipocondríacos dar con el
diagnóstico es un ensayo y error ya no
atacar el trans el trastorno
efectivamente comienza un ciclo de
automedicación pero de médicos generando
gastos hospitalarios
millonarios
puedes tener un seguro pero el que no
pagues la consulta con efectivo no
significa que es gratuita
los pesos económicos a los países son
gigantescos
no todo es negativo
deje de fumar ya no tomo tanto café y
menos con azúcar trato de hacer
ejercicios yo le llamo secuelas
positivas de síntomas pasados así le
llamo yo
según la autora cáncer y quien también
es fundadora de la academia de terapia
cognitiva y profesora de psicología
clínica el mejor enfoque es realizar una
terapia cognitivo-conductual en la que
el paciente aprenda a manejar su
intolerancia a la incertidumbre sobre el
bienestar y detener la búsqueda de la
tranquilidad
la hipocondría es curable
debe dejarse de buscar tranquilidad y
permitirse practicar la exposición a la
incertidumbre no saber con certeza qué
sucederá en el futuro con respecto a la
salud
no controlar el cuerpo no consultar con
las personas no consultar el internet de
forma compulsiva ni hacer preguntas
repetitivas a los médicos
comprendan por favor esto los detonantes
pueden ser de la hipocondría una
espinilla nueva esto me ocurrió la
semana pasada un leve dolor de cabeza
entonces te pones a investigar en qué
parte de la cabeza te duele para saber
qué significa una sutil punzada
estomacal
cuando estos detonantes aparecen
lo que sentimos es un frío un pavor en
el estómago y el este este miedo te
desconecta del mundo tu mente ya no
puede pensar solo quieres averiguar que
tienes que está pasando esto afecta el
trabajo las relaciones familiares las
relaciones con los amigos yo no yo no me
quiero imaginar lo que puede sentir un
médico hipocondríaco porque los hay
acá la solución aparte de intentar no
indagar soltar
dejar el miedo
exponerse de manera imaginaria a los
peores temores sobre esta enfermedad y
sobre la muerte
imaginar repetidamente que se tiene el
diagnóstico más temido hasta
acostumbrarse y que esta ansiedad
disminuya aproximadamente a la mitad
esto lo sugiere la doctora karen
esto a mí me ha funcionado
simplemente me digo ok estoy enfermo
listo moriré mañana pero hoy voy a vivir
hoy voy a disfrutar que se venga lo que
se tenga que venir
otro de otro método sugerido por
especialistas es descargar de internet
una hoja de cálculo de exposición
imaginaria para llevar el control de las
ansiedades es una buena herramienta esto
lo sugiere también la autora casera y
catherine y muchos psicólogos
la intención es exponerte a tus miedos
poco a poco para finalmente enfrentarlos
identificarlos
nadie va a vencer un miedo que no pueda
identificar
además que ver el papel y ver la
cantidad de veces que sufrimos de
ataques de hipocondría eso eso nos va a
impactar sobre todo por la variedad de
enfermedades que podemos llegar a
imaginar en un día en un mes en una
semana es increíble está por supuesto se
la tienes que entregar a tu médico
especialista y él te va a guiar
pero el efecto psicológico que genera
ver la hoja llena con toda la
información ya ya es terapéutico
el ocio es un detonante poderoso más aún
cuando se trata de una persona que está
sola entonces tenemos que realizar
actividades para ocupar la mente y
enfocar la creatividad en cosas
positivas y no en síntomas
aparte de como tú te sientes también
está el tema de cómo se siente la gente
que te rodea hoy entiendo que era por
cariño pero mis amigos vivían haciéndome
bullying cuando les manifestaba que
sentía algún síntoma inclusive me ponían
sobre nombres
ya yo con ello no no no podía hablar
y yo no te lo que tenía cuando en un
solo día sospeche que tenía cáncer un
posible infarto e inicios de un acb
ese día comprendí que algo no andaba
bien y comencé a tratar de calmarme
los médicos no eran opción porque uno de
ellos se burló de mí y decidí ya no
hablar más del tema
pero un día note que mientras más
hablaba de esta situación
más para sentía
entonces decidí que el miedo y la
ansiedad ya no gobernaría más mi vida
cómo lograrlo
en primer lugar ser consciente de mi
situación
aceptarla
hablar de esto sin pena
tomármelo en serio porque si yo no me lo
tomé en serio quien más se lo va a tomar
en serio
enseñar a quienes están a mi alrededor
buscar técnicas y la ayuda psicológica
porque existen
ya se cuenta con programas de trastornos
de humor y ansiedad
mientras más eduquemos sobre este
problema estoy seguro que mucha más
gente va a encontrar una solución y a su
vez
yo solo quiero alzar mi voz y que este
mensaje conecte con más personas y que
genere un cambio de conciencia con
respecto a esta situación
hay mucha gente que necesita ayuda
muchísima
si vives con un hipocondríaco entiende
que su miedo no es voluntario una de las
características de la hipocondría es la
creencia
o sea estamos convencidos de que tenemos
algo
y si eres hipocondríaco
amigo amiga
no tengas miedo de decirlo
soy hipocondríaco pero la ansiedad y el
miedo terminan hoy
[Música]